foreign
comes from Shirley in Wisconsin how do
you feel about women being stay-at-home
moms and not bringing in an income after
they have a baby do you feel like that
is an unwise financial decision first of
all I think it's fan freaking tastic
I think it's the greatest role
in the world
to be a mom to be a full-time mom
stay-at-home mom however you want to
Define it my wife has been a
stay-at-home mom for large portions
there have been Seasons where she has
worked and so into that second part of
the question do you feel like that is
unwise as a financial decision the
answer is no
uh because there there are other
decisions other lifestyle choices
that we make that causes to have
Financial stress but to be a
stay-at-home mom the act of being a
stay-at-home mom is not an unwise
decision in any way now if you've got to
change some Financial things that you've
done but that's something you did
previous to a little one on the way so I
I think I hear the spirit of this Rachel
and just as a male I wanted to sound off
just to say
um
you know I hope no one ever looks down
at that role it's an important season
and uh no one should shame a mom for
wanting to work at home uh because
that's what it is it is working at home
I mean it's not like you're eating bon
bons yeah I'm like oh my God you're not
staying anywhere you were running so
would you add to that as a professional
model yeah I mean I would say you're
saving on Child Care yeah think about
all I mean they they there was a study
that was run and it was basically like
all of the mileage the average mom
drives uh the food that she cooks uh the
house that she cleans all the child care
provide all of it and it's like 1.2
million dollars or something nearly if
you were to Outsource all of that which
I know that but the errands that Stacy
runs for us all of it not just for me
you hold your family together I mean it
is so I think that Stacy is the CEO of
the Coleman household and I have no
problem saying that oh for sure I don't
feel weak I don't feel less than I mean
she's the chief executive officer
there's no question now we do so it's
fascinating too the whole stadium little
bit of the discussion when it comes to
money and even when you talk about debt
because there are a lot of moms where
they are motivation to get out of debt
is to go home because they're like if I
don't have these bills I don't need my
income uh and then for other people
while they're getting out of debt a
stay-at-home mom may say hey I'm gonna
go work part-time uh to make some income
to get out of debt even faster right so
like there's always seasons of life
regardless but no as this if there's a
black and white question of is it unwise
unwise decision when it comes to
finances no or family No in fact it's a
gift it is a huge gift so um thanks for
the question though surely